هذا الاحتجاج الأويغوري الهادئ خارج
القنصلية السعودية سيئة السمعة في اسطنبول هو
سباق مع الزمن
مصير والد نورمان معلق في
الميزان
إذا عاد إلى الصين ، فسيتم
سجنه وهناك
خطر الموت تخبرنا أنها وأختها
فقدت الاتصال بوالدتهما في
منطقة شينجيانغ في الصين قبل أربع سنوات ،
إذا لا سمح الله فقدنا والدنا أيضًا
فسوف تدمرنا ، تقول إن
والدها حمدة لولي ، وهو عالم مسلم من الأويغور ،
ألقي القبض عليه من قبل السلطات السعودية
في نوفمبر بينما كان في رحلة حج إلى
أقدس مدينة في الإسلام.
تركيا
حيث يقيم
ليس في الصين بالنسبة لوالدها ، لا يزال هناك
متسع من الوقت
للآخرين. هناك أمل ضئيل
يقول النشطاء إن
خمسة من الأويغور على الأقل قد تم
ترحيلهم بالفعل من المملكة العربية السعودية.
ما يبدو
أنه
حملة مرعبة من قبل الصين على
مدار تحقيقنا ، وجدنا أيضًا
حالات لإجبار الأويغور على إعادة  تحولوا
إلى الصين
من الإمارات العربية المتحدة ومصر
انتهاكًا للقانون
الدولي وحيث قد يواجهون ما وصفته الولايات المتحدة
بأنه إبادة جماعية
المملكة العربية السعودية لم تستجب الإمارات العربية المتحدة في مصر
لطلباتنا للتعليق
الصين هي شريك تجاري رئيسي لهؤلاء
المسلمين  - دول الأغلبية
التي لم تغض الطرف
عن معاملة الصين للأويغور فقط ، أعربت
حكوماتها الاستبدادية أيضًا
عن دعمها لما تصر الصين على
أنه حملة لمكافحة الإرهاب
، كانت محمد تخفي سرًا غامضًا
عن أولادها الذين
يحاولون حمايتهم من
الواقع القاسي للعالم أنهم ولدوا في
كابوس تبعهم على بعد
آلاف الكيلومترات من وطنهم في
شينجيانغ ،
وهي تخبرهم أن والدها يعمل بعيدًا
آخر مرة سمعت فيها من زوجها
ماتا روزي أنه كان محتجزًا في
مصر في 16 يوليو
2017.
قلت إنك
أنت غالي ،
أحبك كثيرًا
والمشاكل
موجودة لم
أتلق أي رسالة عنه
كانت مريم تعيش حلمها  هل درست هي
ومطار في جامعة الأزهر بالقاهرة
وتزوجا وكونا أسرة ، لكن
عندما وصلت ذراع الصين الطويلة إلى مصر
، سارعوا للخروج ، وتقول
إنها سافرت إلى تركيا مع الأولاد
، ومع ورود تقارير عن اعتقالها في
المطار ، حاول مطر الزواج  كانت العبارة
متجهة إلى الأردن
ولكن تم إيقافها ،
ولم يكن بمقدور مريم فعل الكثير
لمحاولة العثور على زوجها ،
فقد كتبت رسائل إلى وكالات الأمم المتحدة
والحكومات ، لكنها تقول إن
أحداً لم يستجب لم يتم الاعتراف باحتجاز قذائف الهاون
مثل الآخرين الذين اختفى للتو دون أي
أثر
تصدقه السلطات المصرية  لتتصرف
بناءً على طلب من الحكومة الصينية ،
اعتقلت العشرات
من الأويغور ، وربما مئات من الأويغور ، أُعيد
أكثر من عشرين طالبًا قسراً إلى
الصين وفقًا لجماعات حقوق الإنسان ،
وقد توسعت الحملة الصينية على الأويغور
إلى ما هو أبعد من حدودها.  رقم 21
ولكن ليس الرقم الدقيق ربما سيكون
أكثر من عبد الله
ناشط أضعف يقول
إنه وثق 28 مستودعًا على الأقل  من
قبل هذه البلدان في الشرق الأوسط ،
لكن لا أحد يعرف حقًا عدد الأشخاص الأضعف الذين
قد يكونون خلف القضبان في المنطقة أو
عدد الأشخاص الذين تم ترحيلهم بالفعل إلى
الصين في
كثير من الأحيان يخشى أفراد الأسرة من أن الإعلان
للجمهور لن يؤدي إلا إلى تفاقم الأمور بالنسبة
لأحبائهم المختفين
.  موت أطفالي ، فقدان ذاكرة عبد الله
يعذبه
الشعور بالذنب المدمر ، هل دفعت كثيرًا
، ألم تفعل ما يكفي لمحاولة إنقاذ
زوجها ،
إنها تخشى أن تدفع الأسرة في الصين
ثمن حديثها علنًا الآن ،
لكنها تقول إن الصمت لم يعد خيارًا
في  عامين ، هذا النوع من الشعور بالذنب
دائمًا
بداخلي وأنا غير قادر على النوم غير قادر على
الإعجاب حتى إذا شعرت بالسعادة ، فليس لدي
الحق في الشعور بالسعادة ، ليس لدي الحق
في الابتسام
أنا أعيش مثل
هذه  عاش الزوج أحمد طالب وعمل
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة لمدة 10 سنوات
في فبراير 2018 ، تم اعتقاله أثناء
استلامه الأوراق من مركز شرطة دبي
بعد أسبوعين من الجحيم بالنسبة
لامانيس حامل في الشهر التاسع  يطارد ابنها
أحمد أثناء تنقله بين
مراكز الشرطة
والسجون ، أخشى
أن يتم ترحيل زوجي ، إذا لم أستعجل ، فأنا
قلق عليه حقًا في ذلك الوقت ،
أشعر بالعجز الشديد ولا
يوجد أحد.  يمكن أن تساعدني في ذلك الوقت ،
فهذه هي الوثيقة التي حصلت عليها من
المحكمة ، نعم ، تقول لا أحد
سيخبرها بما اتهم به أحمد فقط أنه مطلوب من الصين ، وتؤكد هذه الوثيقة التي حصلت عليها أمنيسا من
النيابة العامة في دبي طلب تسليم صيني
يذكر أيضًا أن النيابة
قررت إغلاق القضية لأن
السلطات الصينية فشلت في تقديم
المستندات المطلوبة
ولكن تم نقل أحمد إلى أبو ظبي
وبعد بضعة أيام
قيل لفقدان الذاكرة أنه أعيد إلى
الصين
إذا كان زوجي قد ارتكب أي جريمة فقد ارتكب
أي جريمة لماذا  لم يخبروني
لماذا لا تخبرني الصين بأن أحد أصعب
الأسئلة في حياتي هو أين بقي والدي
موسى البالغ من العمر ثماني سنوات بصور
وذكريات طفولة غير مكتملة.
في دبي ، نعم ،
نحن نصنع
قلعة ، لكن بدون أبي
موسى يقول إنه محظوظ لم تقابل أخته الصغيرة
أمينة والدها مثل عشرات الآلاف من الأويغور الذين
وجدت العائلة ملاذًا لهم في تركيا ،
لكن مع تقوية العلاقات بين الحكومة.
مع الصين ،
يشعر الأويغور بأن مساحتهم الآمنة
تتقلص
أخت إصبعها مع عدم وجود أي مكان آخر
لتدير ominissa تقول إنها طلبت ذات مرة
الاتجاهات
إلى البحر أقول إنني أريد أن آخذ طفلي ،
أريد أن أجلس هناك في الواقع ، ما
أريد فعله هو أنني أريد ذلك  ادخل إلى الداخل لأنني
لا أعرف كيف
أسبح يسأل أمينيسا هل هذا العالم ليس كبيرًا
بما يكفي للضعفاء
جيمانا كراتشي سي إن إن اسطنبول